hi i'm anjali crochet good morning
comic-con are you excited to find out
what it means to be at a Marvel
character exclusive spotlight I'm gonna
try to get are you excited well I'm
gonna give you a little bit of a hint
the character we're spotlighting might
be standing right next to me at least
the character costume yesterday they
announced that there is a brand new
addition to Marvel's Avengers and it is
going to be Kamala Khan so I could sit
here and talk about Kamala Khan all
morning but I want to invite a couple of
very special friends up here who know a
little bit more about the character than
I do and definitely know more about how
the character was developed for this
amazing amazing game I would like to
bring up first writer and creative
director of Marvel's Avengers Shana Skye
yes yes you Shawn
next up I would like to bring the
performance actor behind the performance
of Kamala Khan for Marvel's Avengers
Sandra Saad and a very special guest
that we have with us this morning two of
the co-creators of Kamala Khan first I
would like to bring up the original
writer and co-creator of Kamala Khan G
willow Wilson
and last but certainly not least
co-creator of Kamala Kahn and VP content
and character development and Marvel
Sarah
amana's you guys could take a seat don't
sit on your mics though don't sit on
your mics that might be rude for the the
audience well good morning everyone it's
been so long since I've seen you years
right I mean by years you mean yesterday
miss you dear I've I've missed you
terribly
how would you sleep did you sleep fine I
did because I knew that the world knew
that you were come on the Kahn girl I
couldn't sleep at all I was like this is
too exciting all right so we're gonna
jump right into it and I'm gonna go all
the way to the far end so G willow sana
you created this amazing amazing amazing
incredible marvelous character that so
many people are already I see cosplay
already out there for Kamala this
morning and we've chatted a lot Sona
about Kamala mm-hmm for those who may
not be familiar with MS Marvel and her
backstory and may be new or just want to
hear it all over again can you tell us a
little bit about who she is and and
where she came from not for me or for
well go for it
let's tag-team this will oh okay see
blacker and I called up right over there
called up Miss will Wilson over here and
and said hey we have an idea for a
Muslim American superhero and she's like
you guys are insane I'm paraphrasing and
but we had no other ideas besides that
really let's just make a thing and
Willow came back with some really fun
ideas we had some bad ideas we had some
bad yeah it was it was the longest I
think development time that I've done on
a series because we wanted to make sure
that we got this character exactly right
that she felt very real I mean there was
so there's some deep conversations that
we had early on during the development
process because I think anytime you're
trying to do something new especially in
superhero comics you have to create a
world that will support that character
and get those notes right and you know
Sanne and I are both Jersey girls you
know we we had a lot sort of in common
and so there was some obvious building
blocks to sort of put together and I
think the time and the effort that we
and Steve and Adrian Alfano the original
series artists put in really showed
because you know we were able to create
this this cohesive world for this
character
so for those out there who love Kamala
and are just want to know some things
what were three things that you had to
have as a character for Kamala well I
think that the biggest thing was making
sure that she was just a regular
teenager like just very grounded I
remember like the first when willow
turned in the first script and you see
Kamala's face plastered against the
window of a like a bacon and like like a
bacon grilling machine and her first
line in Marvel Comics history is I just
want to smell it I feel like that
encapsulates like everything that we
wanted for that character like young
relatable and just funny yeah right I
think it's you know when you come out
with a new superhero there's a certain
set of expectations that I think we were
trying to undermine not to say like oh
you know there's there's a bus on fire
and out of the sky comes superhero X
yeah you know her origin story was a lot
more down-to-earth she starts out kind
of like you know any of us encountering
the Marvel Universe first as a fan and
you know sort of as a regular teen who's
trying to balance school and family and
friends and just growing up and figuring
out who she is as a person and so you
know we wanted to sort of drop people
into the story on a very regular day
with her sort of going about her
life with her friends and doing her
schoolwork and like hanging out at the
circle queue which is like the local
convenience store so people would go
like oh hey I haven't I haven't really
seen a superhero origin story like this
in a while so I mean it was a risk but I
think it really paid off in the end
so now that we know a little bit about
Kamala can we take a look at Kamala Khan
and Marvel's Avengers you want that yes
please oh I could watch this all day
what is your name I was just some weird
kid from Jersey who didn't fit in I kind
of stole something off of Ames sur Mer
huh what why why Amy cost people like
being human claims were sick violet
heart disease what a lesson right well I
don't believe it what if the Avengers
were set up
aim the so-called cure it's not lining
up there's something wrong and I can
feel it don't you
the kid isn't human we did this and she
needs your help I can't I can't you
can't what you're ditching me hey don't
take it personally kid no this is what
he does
this was a mistake
so you're both just gonna walk away The
Avengers were set up cap was murdered
think I don't know that I've replayed
that day in my head a thousand times
that's what no one cares the world
needed someone to blame and he gave them
their scapegoat so unless you have some
kind of astounding proof I suggest you
both get off my land
what is that proof
[Music]
Maulik on guys it's such a good trailer
but my favorite part is always the end
that Slurpee was fun and it's a circle
cue cup for Fanta
all right Sandra yeah you are literally
Kamala Khan literally when you first
auditioned for this role when you were
cast did you did you have any idea how
integral this character would be to this
game no I had I had no idea anything you
know when you're first auditioning
especially for a Marvel project they you
know change all the names they change
all the details so you have no idea even
what you're auditioning for but I knew
right away that I loved whoever this was
and I was like I don't care what this is
but I want it and I came back like for
like my fourth audition or something I
was like still don't know what this is
but I loved it
and then when I found out I was like no
way an Avenger Kamala Khan and the more
I read up about her the more I was just
like I love her I love her I love her
and every single day on set just kind of
became more and more like I tell you
this all the time but like every time I
show up on set I'm like well that was
the best day of my life nothing can top
this and then I show up again the next
month and I'm like well that was the
best day of my life nothing can top this
but that that brings us really back to
what Sunna and G willow we're talking
about which is this concept of
relatability and you actually have like
a very personal connection to Kamala as
a character correct yes
I like Kamala I'm a first generation
American I grew up you know with the
strict parent
you know like I've got my own I'm a fan
girl of my own things I'm a fan girl of
the Avengers I mean y'all are too you
get it and you know like my parents
don't really get it and like that's fine
but you know I definitely being maybe
also a first-generation American you
grow up kind of just wanting to be
accepted and you know for whatever your
your likes are and for who you really
are and you know Kamala definitely has
that struggle of feeling a little bit
like an other and wanting to belong and
feel accepted so so yeah I relate to her
so much and I don't know any one person
who's never had that struggle so I feel
like anybody can relate to her does your
mom know what you do yet has she figured
it out after yesterday oh she's been
googling my mom sent me the trailer
yesterday she's like is this you like
wow I love her she's watching hi mom
alright so Sean we've had a couple
conversations you are so excited about
this all right I don't excite I know
there's a lot of fans of Kamala Khan but
you're like in the top ten in my book
I appreciate that you really are like I
from from the moment you the words
Kamala Khan came out of your mouth I
realized that this was a very important
story for you but also you've played
such a big role into creating the story
and involving Kamala and integrating the
character into the game can you set a
little bit of the scene for us around
the events in the game and and why why
it's so important that it's Kamala yeah
well you know one I'm super excited to
get this part of the story because you
don't know how much time the the studio
the fans everyone's just been just
knocking our outdoors Y what tell us the
story you guys got to tell us the story
I don't get it
so we're super excited to reveal Kamala
and on the events of a day and the story
that you guys saw some of you saw the
early trailer releases you know the
Avengers you know they brought out their
new technology they were displaying
their healthcare
a custom chimera with this new energy
source that went just totally arrived
was destructive to San Francisco leveled
the city a lot of people got injured and
they kind of left on this low note
Kamala was there on a day and was also
affected by that reactor right and some
of you saw the hints or saw some of the
you know little Peaks that we sent out
of her falling on the on the on the deck
right but the the sad part about that
day was that the Avengers are now
outlawed super powers are now outlawed
so an aim which is this corporation
that's kind of risen up in the in the
absence of superheroes they've kind of
sold this world protected by science so
here you have Kamala and the irony
behind Kamala she went to this a day
celebrations just seeking sort of
validation right she's got a comic she's
an Avenger too she loves the you know
the group she's the ultimate fan yeah
and she wants to be just like everyone
else and then she gets infected
quote-unquote infected by you know aim
terms by this Terrigen mist and now is
even further outcast so it's awesome
it's an awesome set up to see this
journey of this unassuming hero who has
all the right qualities to unite these
Avengers against a well and at the
Marvel games panel yesterday you
mentioned that it's such a big deal that
Kamala is doing it because she has such
faith in the Avengers who don't have
faith in themselves right because there
is a little bit uh there's a little bit
of a conflict going on with the Avengers
at the moment particularly between Bruce
and Tony a couple people are out dealing
with their guilts but you have this
ultimate fan girl who has come in you
know
Sandra how does it feel to be tasked
with reassembling the Avengers like what
was it like to team up one with the
Avengers but with this team that's been
working together for so long oh man they
are such a welcoming group of people and
I feel
like being around Troy and Nolan and
Laura and Jeff and and every single
person on the cast and crew has been I
mean we feel like a family and so much
almost like Kamala and the Avengers
every time I'm on set I feel like I'm
Kamala standing amongst the Avengers
because these guys just welcomed me with
open arms in fact they're here right now
supporting me listening to all of this
and hey guys be organized in a minute
there's gonna be a sighting oh but let
me get to the signing though I kind of
want to skip over can we play the
gameplay video real quick because I I
know we have to wrap very shortly to get
to the signing but I don't want to miss
out on that if we can Tony check it out
[Music]
[Music]
ah so good
okay so Kamala has some incredible moves
in this game you got to do a lot of work
on vocab and I want to talk very very
quickly because but a lot of people
don't know is that you are a performance
actor which means you're not just the
voice you are literally doing the
movements they have based the emotions
off of your face you have done a lot of
work in here but also because Kamala has
such unique powers there is a lot of
stuff that was done differently with how
she's doing her gameplay what were some
of your inspirations in creating her
moves Shawn and then how is that
experience because Sandra's are gonna be
like no I don't know this is not a
question for me
no it's not and how is that experience
Sandra because I know this is your first
time doing this yeah it is my first time
when when Shawn explains to me what a
what a clap is the only reference I have
is a comic and I'm like great how do i
how do I like clap and then my hands
grow all the way to the end of the room
but then you know they they crystal is
very very good about showing me stuff
when it's ready and showing me what it's
supposed to look like what it's gonna
look like and that is so cool seeing all
of the details come to life it makes it
if Shawn's explanation actually makes it
very very easy Oh put me on the spot now
it's a craft it's a craft we had a lot
of great reference you know from the
comics we took a lot of our initial
animation tests from it right out of the
book we wanted her to be powerful and
and directing Santa was was easy because
she's very imaginatively right so she's
her imagination is wild on the stage she
will just literally do a thunderclap and
be all in it for like a few minutes
after he'd be like all right
are you sure I could do it again this is
your hawking magic this is literally how
I imagined it don't worry I could do it
better yeah no she literally would say
hey wait no no I got this one one more
right double best double back well we're
gonna talk more about Kamala all day
today but I want to make sure why we
have an opportunity to have all of you
onstage
you know the life and evolution of
Kamala Khan has been a journey that has
spanned five going on six years now and
we're gonna be celebrating the fifth
anniversary a little later on on the
stage today you know it's gone through
animation comics now games each one of
you you have ten seconds what are you
most excited to see for fans to see in
this iteration of Kamala Khan story how
important she actually is the Marvel
Universe and that she's only gonna
become bigger yeah
what a fun character she is to go along
with on her journey not just because of
who she is as a person but by how fun
and interesting her power set is as well
I'm excited for everyone to take away a
little bit of her strength because she
goes through a lot and she's resilient
and she makes her way with hope that
inspires everyone around her I'm excited
for you guys to play
Kamala Khan's coming-of-age story in
this game yeah a lot of people don't
realize that this really is you said
yesterday that it wasn't intended to be
a coming-of-age story but it really has
become that which is so core to the
character of Kamala Khan yes she's
powerful if you're a gamer you're gonna
love that she is super fun to play you
got to see the gameplay it's insane when
her arms stretch they go what it's my
favorite well I want to thank each and
every one of you so so much for being up
here can we get another round of
applause for our panel
well make sure you're sticking around
because next up we are going to be
having a signing of not just Sandra but
the rest of the Marvel Avengers cast and
I get a chance to ask them a couple
questions to learn a little bit more
about the process about putting that
game together but also find out who is
most like their character from the game
thank you so much